hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 15 hört zu und spricht nach
die dusche ist im badezimmer die dusche
ist im badezimmer der herz ist in der
küche der herz ist in der küche
das bett ist im schlafzimmer das bett
ist im schlafzimmer der fernseher steht
im wohnzimmer der fernseher steht im
wohnzimmer die pflanze steht auf dem
balkon die pflanze steht auf dem balkon
wie viele stockwerke hat das haus wie
viele stockwerke hat das haus es hat
drei stockwerke
es hat drei stockwerke
wie ist das badezimmer
das badezimmer es ist es ist groß klein
groß klein hell dunkel hell dunkel neu
alt alt wie viele zimmer hat deine
wohnung wie viele zimmer hat deine
wohnung meine wohnung hat zwei zimmer
meine wohnung hat zwei zimmer wie
ist deine wohnung wie groß ist deine
wohnung
sie ist 93 quadratmeter groß sie ist 93
quadratmeter groß gibt es einen balkon
gibt es einen balkon
ja es gibt einen balkon
nein es gibt keinen balkon
nein es gibt keinen balkon gibt es eine
terrasse gibt es eine terrasse
ja es gibt eine terrasse
nein es gibt keine terrasse
nein es gibt keine terrasse gibt es
einen keller gibt es einen keller
es gibt einen keller ja es gibt einen
keller nein es gibt keinen keller nein
es gibt keinen keller gibt es eine
garage gibt es eine garage es gibt eine
garage ja es gibt eine garage nein es
gibt keine garage nein es gibt keine
garage mir gefällt der kleiderschrank
mir gefällt der kleiderschrank
er ist groß
ist groß ich möchte ihn kaufen
ich möchte ihn kaufen
mir gefällt das bett mir gefällt das
bett es ist bequem
es ist bequem
ich möchte es kaufen
fällt die lampe mir gefällt die lampe
sie ist mutter
sie ist modern
ich möchte
sie kaufen ich möchte
sie kaufen mir gefallen die vorhänge mir
gefallen die vorhänge sie sind schön sie
sind schön
ich möchte sie kaufen
am anfang vom wort am anfang vom wort
das handy das handy das heft das heft
heiß heiß
heute heute helfen helfen
der herd der herd holen holen
das haus das haus die hilfe die hilfe
das hobby das hobby h nach lokalen nach
lokalen 10 10 gehen gehen verstehen
[Musik]
verstehen
der lehrer der lehrer sehen sehen nehmen
nehmen sehr sehr
fahren
fahren der rahmen der rahm das jahr das
jahr die zahl die zahl der bahnhof der
bahnhof bezahlen bezahlen
der stuhl der stuhl die uhr
die uhr
der schuh der schuh
die kuh die kuh wohnen wohnen der
so der sohn
der lohn der lohn das ohr das ohr
die kohlensäure die kohlensäure ohne
ohne er fährt er fährt zählen zählen
er nehme er nehmen
der ungefähr fühlen fühlen
[Musik]
berühmt berühmt früh früh
der frühling der frühling
[Musik]